(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh no!
Look at those legs!
- [Nick] Oh my goodness.
- [AJ] Hi, beautiful!
- Oh my gosh, hello.
I've been very excited.
I always love when musicians come on.
It's just fun.
It's usually a different conversation.
I love you too, actors!
(group laughs)
I just mean like,
it's a different vibe obviously,
'cause we're all singers.
Anyways, so, you know
my band leader, Jason.
- [Nick] Yes, I do actually.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- It's so funny,
so, I had a failed attempt
in being a solo artist,
but that worked out for me.
(group laughs)
- [Kelly] I would not say failed.
- [Howie] There's still time!
- And actually,
Jason was my band leader
and when I failed, then he just...
- Went over to you.
- [Kelly] Thank you, for that.
Thank you.
- [Nick] It worked out, right?
- I was like, "That worked
out for me actually."
He's literally been my
best partner in music
and the only reason why I'm sitting here,
so anyway, he's so great!
(audience claps)
- [Nick] He's amazing!
- He's so talented.
(audience clapping)
- So, you guys..
Give it up for Jason
(imitates trumpet sound)
(group cheers)
So, you guys started
almost thirty years ago,
so, what were those first days like?
'Cause y'all were like really young.
- [Nick] Yeah, I was eleven
when I met these guys.
- You were eleven?
- I was eleven.
- I was fourteen.
Yeah, I mean back in the day,
we used to ride on
basically like a Winnebago.
We were doing what they
called this ESM Tour.
So, we would go around
to like, middle schools,
high schools, gymnasiums, auditoriums,
and perform music that
nobody had ever heard,
and we weren't signed yet.
- We did covers too.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
Covers.
- [AJ] Covers, and...
- That's a hard play though to win over,
like a high school crowd, and like-
- Totally.
- We have some great stories.
- Oh, teenagers can be cruel.
(Brian laughing)
- [Kelly] They're mean!
Yeah, no, that's what I'm saying,
like even when you go to the school
and you're in something with the school,
they're still mean, like people are in.
- [Nick] Yeah.
- We were in...
I think it was somewhere
on the East Coast,
and we're in this auditorium,
we're doing our stuff,
and the entire sound system went out.
No mics, no nothing.
- They pulled the plug!
Like (imitates sound)
- So Brian, is basically
trying to get everybody
to calm down and to stop
yelling and screaming,
and they got really quiet and we just sang
straight acapella, and we won them over.
- Oh, I love that story!
I was hoping (mumbles)
(audience cheers)
- They were standing up, it was amazing.
- You know what though?
That's sometimes the better play.
Like, sometimes, 'cause
we always do big things,
I know people expect big shows from you,
but it is those moments,
and I know Floyd agrees,
but it's those moments
when you do something
like really I don't know,
broken down like that,
that really just showcases
the real talent behind,
you know, it's kind of a cool moment.
So, that's probably why,
just not everybody can do that.
- Well, it shows that you're real,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, what we do is real.
All five of us singing together.
- [Kelly] Absolutely!
- Just as you know as a singer,
I mean that's-
- [Kelly] And that's really hard to do
with a bunch of y'all.
- That's what we came to do.
- [Nick] That's what
we pride ourselves on.
- That's what we came to
do, so we just did it,
and they were like... (gasps)
- They were like harmonies.
Since day one, we've
always picked up songs.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Boyz II Men, Shai,
Jodeci, Color Me Badd,
we loved the doo-wop evo
groups back in the days.
- [Nick] Temptations...
- We loved just picking
out all those harmonies
and that's where we got
our signature sound,
it was based around harmonies.
- That's so awesome.
I'm glad you had that
'cause I'm sure we all had those moments
when things went like that,
and then we have moments
where they didn't go great,
and you were like, "Am I talented?"
(group laughing)
And you have those moments
you're like, "Should I quit?"
That was personally for me
when I saw you two perform
at Madison Square Garden, I
was like "What am I doing?"
I was like, "I should probably quit."
Anyway, when Machine Gun Kelly was here,
he said he was a huge fan of you
and he also had this to say,
so we wanted to show you.
- I went to a Backstreet Boys concert,
and I threw up on the first song
(Kelly laughs)
because the girls were so loud,
they were screaming so loud,
I don't know how that equaled
out to me throwing up,
but,
(audience laughs)
- It's overwhelming!
- I know it happened though.
- Yeah.
- Like, they came down
on these hover boards,
and everyone was going so crazy
and I was going like,
(mimics barfing)
(Kelly grunts)
(audience laughing)
(all laughing)
- They're intense!
(audience claps)
They're intense! They're loud!
- Fortunately, we hadn't-
- [Nick] Awesome story.
- Started singing yet, so
that wasn't why he threw up,
- [Kelly] No!
- So, that's a good thing.
That's a good thing.
- He made it to the show.
- It's overwhelming!
He did, we talked about it.
No, he loved it, but my point though
is like it's a different vibe
especially with boy bands,
like, it's a different
ball game, the fans.
- It is, yeah.
- 'Cause I've got a few
friends that actually work
on like y'all's tour, other peoples' tour,
do things like backstage
like meet and greet things
for y'all, and it's like a
different kind of fandom.
Like, they really are invested
from a young age and it's loud.
- It's loud, yeah.
- I mean, we like to say we have-
(audience members scream)
I mean, it is loud.
- [Kelly] It's like a different frequency.
- What? What?
- [Nick] We miss that. We miss that.
- It's been years since hearing that.
- It's been two years
since we've performed.
- What'd you say? I'm sorry.
- I know, but that's the
thing for a lot of artists.
Like, everybody hasn't been able to do
what they've really wanted to do.
So, are y'all so excited
about doing this tour?
- [Group] Oh, yeah.
- It's time.
- Excited to get back out to the fans.
- We've been chomping at the bit.
(group laughs)
- Yeah.
- Just sitting at home, eating,
waiting to go out on the road.
- Driving our wives crazy.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] Well, that can be...
- [Nick] And honestly, I feel now,
especially with the way
everything is in the world,
it's like entertainment
is so needed right now.
Like, our job is so important
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- To get people's minds off this stuff.
(audience applauding)
- [AJ] Music!
- And just to be in a room
and with people that you don't know,
and you're all like vibing on one thing,
I love that feeling.
- [Nick] Yeah, it's a
different kind of energy
and we thrive on that energy.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- You know what I mean?
Don't get me wrong,
our kids were so happy that we were home
for this last two years, but-
- Were your wives? (laughs)
- But our wives are glad.
Our wives are glad now that
we're getting out of the house.
- Our wives were like, "You
have to go back to work!
Please go back to work!"
- I had two babies born
during that time, well prior.
(audience applauds)
- Aw, that's so cool.
I'm happy for you.
They just added more dates
to their DNA World Tour
with cities including, Portland,
Cincinnati and Nashville,
shout out Nashville!
(audience members cheering)
Tickets for these and other
just added cities in the US,
Canada and Europe go on
sale this Friday, April 8th.
So, Kevin, what can the fans
expect to see on this tour?
What's different?
(group laughs)
(Kevin stutters)
(audience laughs)
- He was like, "And..."
- He likes to think about
things before he says them.
- He's like, "What?"
- He's a thoughtful man.
- I think this show
is a great example of our musical legacy.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
(audience claps)
- Like, we're able to...
We have...
- [Kelly] Do you take people on that run?
(audience continues cheering)
- We have all the hits that
the fans know and love,
we have some new music,
and then some gems that were on the albums
that are our favorite that
we included in the set
that people are like, "Oh my
God, I forgot about that song!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we're excited to be
taking the show outdoors.
- [Brian] Thirty-two!
(group chattering)
- [Kelly] Did you just say..
- Thirty-two songs!
- Oh yeah, so the first half
of the tour is going to be..
- Thirty two songs?!
- Yeah, thirty two songs-
- What?
(audience screams)
- [Kevin] Ten albums..
- Are they like medleys in there?
- There's an intermission,
no, I'm kidding.
- And they're choreographed.
(group chattering)
- Oh my God, as a vocalist,
I just died. (chuckles)
- And we're dancing the whole show too.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [Brian] This is what we do, Kelly.
We're a group, for sure.
- I love that.
That's awesome.
(group laughs)
No, I love that you're like dancing
and like meanwhile I'm like,
"I'm not going on stairs.
I'm not using stairs"
(group laughs)
I won't even get on stairs.
I'm like "Nah, people
ain't coming to watch me
stand on stairs, I'm gonna trip.
I'm not Beyonce."
(group laughs)
So, wait, has getting back
to performance and all that,
'cause you say you're dancing a lot,
so is that getting
y'all in shape for that?
'Cause that's a different kind of...
- We have to get in shape.
I mean that's the thing
about the pandemic.
I mean I put on like twenty,
twenty-five pounds. (chuckles)
- Time off for us is like anything.
- I definitely didn't lose weight, Nick,
so, yeah.
- [Nick] You look beautiful!
- And vocal shape though!
Vocal shape as well.
- [Nick] Yeah, that's a thing too.
- Yeah.
- I went the other way.
- We started rehearsal like a week ago.
We got about five
rehearsals under our belt,
and we got another month to go,
and then we'll be ready to rock.
(audience cheers)
- That's awesome.
Do you ever have that moment
where you haven't done a show in a while,
and then all of a sudden,
I feel so awkward,
I'm like, "So I guess I'll
walk to this side of the stage,
and then I'll walk over here,"
I always have this right when I get back,
I'm like, "What do I do?"
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "I literally just sing",
I always do that.
Maybe y'all don't,
because you're like cool
and you have choreography but like...
- Yeah.
(group laughs)
- But I don't, so I'm always
like, "How do I do this again?
I haven't done it in a while."
- Well, our thing is if
you don't know what to do,
fill in the space.
- Yeah. Totally.
- 'Cause you know,
- [Kelly] Oh.
- If you're clumped up over,
oh, no, spread out, fill in the space.
- Yeah.
- Just take up space on the stage.
- That's so fun that y'all
get to do that like as a team.
- [AJ] Yeah.
- [Kevin] Yup.
- That's so fun.
- Break!
- Two!
(audience members laughing)
- He has his moments. (laughs)
- You gotta think about
it too with traffic.
We call it traffic, because
we all have certain moves
that we do where we cross each other,
something like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, if we haven't done it in a while...
(audience laughs)
- We'll take off and like...boom! (claps)
- That's the show I wanna see!
- We're like, "Ow! My bad!"
- [AJ] That's the show you wanna go see?
- That's the show I wanna see.
- It'd be interesting.
(all laughing)
- Speaking about that,
there's something internally in the group,
we would call someone
in this group 'Train'
for a particular reason.
(audience laughs)
Because he would run into the other guys
during that traffic.
(audience laughing)
I'm not gonna call him out
and tell you who it is.
- [Kelly] He said no.
(audience laughs)
- He's calling himself out.
- I'm just gonna say,
maybe they are in your way,
is the thing.
(all laughing)
- Exactly. That's what I'm saying.
- [Nick] Could be.
- Get out the way, move.
Get out the way.
- Move! Get out the way!
- It could be that.
- [Kelly] That's amazing! That's awesome.
Wait, so AJ, speaking of
getting back into shape,
so, you found a TikTok
video that Howie did, right?
- Yup.
(audience wows)
- [Kelly] Okay, we're just
gonna show a little of this.
(audience cheers)
Okay.
- [Nick] This is hilarious.
- [AJ] It's so good.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] This is good.
(cheering continues)
- [AJ] It's so good.
- [Kelly] Look at you coming in here.
Get it D! (laughs)
- [AJ] I'm like, "C'mon, bruh".
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I mean, first of
all, that looks so hard.
- [AJ] That's the best part!
That's the best part!
(audience clapping)
- Oh my god, if someone
asked me to do that last one
right now, I'd just die.
I would just die.
- That's the best part
of that video (imitates climbing sound)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I saw a couple other guys
posting some workout videos,
and I decided to get on the bandwagon-
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- And show them how to really do it.
- I gotta be honest with you,
(audience cheers)
that last one, if I could do it right now,
I would post it just to
say that I could do it,
like I did it.
(AJ laughing)
I'm not into like...
I used to do kick boxing on
tour and it would wear me out,
especially amphitheater tours,
I don't know if y'all ever did that
and you'd walk in on those
hills like the back part.
- [Group] Oh, yeah.
- I call that 'Hell', yeah.
(group laughs)
(group chattering)
- Yeah, get that cardio going.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- Yeah, I've seen artists
like singing on treadmills.
Like I've seen Katy Perry do
it, I've seen Miley do it,
I've tried it, and it's really hard to do.
Like, just sing your music
while you're running on the treadmill-
- [Kelly] Do you know what's harder?
- To get your endurance up.
- I like swimming, so if
you swim and you can't sing,
obviously because you're
swimming, your mouth's closed
but you hum, (sighs heavily)
- Oh, that's a new one.
- [Kelly] It is, 'cause
swimming in general
kind of improves your lung capacity,
and it's just better on your,
I sound old, on your joints,
(all laughing)
- Yup. I know.
- 'Cause I used to run like all the time
and I used to do that,
and I found that it wasn't
actually helpful for me.
- Walking is just as
good, you know honestly.
Like seriously.
- We are so old!
(all laughing and clapping)
- Reality check!
- [Kelly] Walking is so good for you.
Walking is better for your neck, and...
- Walking is better for your knees.
- No, it's amazing, I
do see y'all on stage
and I'm like, "Oh my god,
they are getting it".
I'm like, "Ah, I feel like such a loser."
- Forty four is the new twenty four, man.
Let's go. Let's go!
(audience cheers)
Let's go!
(cheering continues)
- Wait, so, Kevin, we all
made some choices in the 90's
with fashion, so I'm gonna start with you,
what are some of your best/worst moments?
We all have them. I'm
gonna start with you.
You're welcome.
(group laughs)
- Thank you. You're welcome.
- I like to put you on the
spot, 'cause you're a thinker.
- One of the worst things
is when we first broke
in Europe, we would go over there
and we'd spend sometimes
three months at a time.
And you go to a magazine shoot,
and they want to get as much
content from you as possible,
so you do like ten different looks.
And this one look, we were in the UK,
we were doing a cover
for Smash Hits magazine
and they gave us these shiny, silk shirts-
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Good start.
- And we're all holding disco balls.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- I remember that. I remember that.
- That's probably one of the worst-
- [Kelly] You're wearing
silk shirts holding balls,
that's awesome.
(all laughing)
- [AJ] Yeah, and our makeup was so white.
Our makeup was the...
- Really like silvery-
- [Kelly] I like it.
- Those were in in the 90's,
but it just didn't look good
and we all had way too much makeup on.
- I bet it looked great.
- At that age, we didn't need makeup then,
we were young.
I don't know why we had makeup on,
but they put make up
on us, it looked crazy.
(AJ mumbles)
So, that's one of the worst,
and yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Brian] Look, that's
when they colored my hair!
- [Kelly] You guys are
like babies right now...
- [Brian] They colored my hair
red, I was like, "Foreal?"
- [Kelly] I love that.
(audience sighs)
- [Howie] That was our Caesar hair.
- [AJ] That was when the
Caesar haircuts were a thing
back in the nineties.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Caesar haircuts?
Is that what it's called?
- [AJ] Yeah, Caesar haircut.
- [Kelly] I didn't even
know it was called that.
(group chattering)
- [AJ] Yeah the bangs.
- [Howie] Yeah, they called them Caesar.
- And you know what that was called?
For the people that don't know,
that's called a land line.
That was a telephone.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] A landline?
- [Brian] That was actually
a landline. A rotary.
- [Kelly] I always think of Roseanne.
I always think of Roseanne, the show.
She'd like have that
phone everywhere. (laughs)
- [AJ] Oh, yeah.
- Okay, so we have a
surprise for you. (laughing)
Everybody, tickets for the DNA
World Tour are on sale now!
Newly added dates go on
sale this Friday but,
no one in this audience
has to wait until then
because you're all getting
tickets to a show of your choice!
(audience screams)
- Yay!
The Backstreet Boys DNA
World Tour kicks off
in Las Vegas this week.